hi I'm Ryan Wright and I'm cat Das and
what is very professional sorry again
okay we're not starting again this is
raw footage that's what we're doing
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
dawn of the Planet of the Apes oh you
seen the first one the original well no
not Astin yeah well I'll have you yeah
impressive that makes you more
attractive so yeah we're gonna watch the
second trailer for it the one that the
one that James Frank the sequel to the
one that James Frankel isn't okay I
never saw that one you never saw that
one it's really good awesome
and you'll notice we're not in my place
today right cats well where there's
roommates here we're just idly senator
computers yeah it's exactly what you
think it's like me you see cat you're
like roommates there's gonna be hotter
roommates - as hot roommates everywhere
man that's what it's like here and it's
exactly what all you guys are thinking -
the craziest hottest stuff goes down
with your er alone pillow fights
everything you've ever imagined it
happens it's crazy
catch that has some stories right
totally yeah way to play along again
proud of you you like should be earlier
I never play alone yeah you're doing a
good job Bridget actually do the
lighting for us thank you sort of yeah
Thank You Bridget thank you so IRA both
lit today yeah
and Taylor's into Jewish guys or
something like that oh thank you didn't
I was trying to give background
information on who's in the room with
that in mind let's watch the trailer
pretty dawn of the Planet of the I'm
actually excited to see this because I
love the first one that you did not see
yeah I mean I like the originals yeah I
know well this is about when they were
like really starting to rise oh yeah was
it those rise the plan of you that's
what you think Rise of the Planet Eve's
is about mine either dawning okay so
it's all Sun terms oh yeah that's a good
point
so eventually they'll set yeah set in
the blood it's Taylor bridge you guys
making way too much noise
way too much noise you're being very
obnoxious right now Aneesa stuff
oh it's it's I'm laughing but I'm really
terrified at the same time actually
because anytime I kick him out any time
a girl gets mad at me it's really
terrifying actually
here we go that's cool CG I do they are
we're cool OCG
that looks really realistic actually
it's gonna be us one day cat
I'm just living in peace I know I want
to be an ape so bad so they can read and
write but they still talk like that yeah
they just started learning Oh I never
pulled a gun out of me who would eat
girls it's not wood here sweet that I
can't
it looks like what interested it's not
there is it who is like I never do this
looks excited there's a virus created by
scientists in a lab it can't blame eggs
what the hell's and we're gonna play do
the acting looks you're really good
actually cloning if we have to fight the
weak foot there is nothing how did you I
need to speed sugar
guys akula's leaves you and I don't want
to take it away from you I promise but
I'll pick up exactly hey really yeah
you're just making any sense to you
ah I've seen things I've seen the way
they are they want what we wanted to
survive they don't going to turn on you
this is gonna be intense I feel it they
ride horses what yeah better faster than
horses oh wow
whoa war
so excited Britta's interesting I really
you don't share the same enthusiasm I
have no I think it looks pretty good
actually
monkey fighting yeah monkey fighting
that's a you know if you call them a
monkey they would get really offended
I'm sorry Apes yeah I don't wanna look
into your eyes for too long why because
um how's a chance that their own a
compliment people you're pretty this one
a while to think of one yeah I know and
I came out with a very basic compliment
anyway yeah the movie does look really
awesome yeah I'm pretty excited to watch
it I think I have to see the first one
you do then you'll probably get a little
more sensitive in the characters yeah
because you get to see who's Caesar was
in the last one okay so you remember
them oh yeah did Caesar was awesome okay
what they sound like would you ever date
a guy who sounded like that crap like
Christian Bale want to hook up Luca Oh
Oh God now be a sex noises be humping
you and just no girlfriend yeah that's
true I love the tone that's going on I'm
really happy about - is that the acne
actually was really good like it doesn't
look like just some overblown science
fiction movie that looks like it's
taking its time you know it's gonna have
some actual human emotion going on human
emotion but it's about face shape
emotion ape emotion yeah I think oh I
need to go back watch the first one I
agree I agree thank you cuz right now
it's very disappointing the way you're
feeling really don't look into my eyes
if you're new to the channel sort of
school
yeah it's up above us oh my Diddy Kong
noise that's pretty good do you know who
did he calling us yeah I think I know
who did he call you guys the sad because
I played off no I played I played I
think all the Donkey Kong games actually
really all I think I played like Donkey
Kong and like Donkey Kong Country was
like the second one
no is non-count country was the first
one what was the second one you are just
really there's more so higher honor okay
that was a while ago there is the first
one then there was one pirates and then
there was another one oh that was that
was diddy kong's adventure and Donkey
Kong - yeah that's yes OCAD have you
done shout out to me alright guys it's
that time of the video the one that
everyone
gets mad at me enough we're not saying
their name now you're lucky three is
gonna hear your name we're going in
order that's what we do so where are we
what number are we on Marian Zamora good
for you for wanting a shout out yes a
two people request the shadow no I'm
actually better with the people who like
insult me and then ask for a shout-out
you're right how are you yes I'm already
like yours what they said about me and
then Diane there's no last name just
Diane oh no I already did that well
she's getting another shout out hi Diane
yeah Marian that's a hot name actually I
like that name isn't there actress like
a grandmother name what my great you
totally know how to like honor kill
right there
notary kill off of a woman I made up in
my mind I think you're a girl I don't
know if you're a girl actually marrying
me a guys named Marian could be a guys
name like an old-fashioned gentleman
yeah totally like the hottest issue
you've ever seen has dreams absent no he
drinks absently you know like a
gentleman from like you know the
absinthe era ha she's not just looks
people she also has a brain is that
awesome
Victor Alejandro you know there yeah
Victor Alejandro communi beer
Victor Alejandro Camino Vera that's a
complicated name why would your parents
name you that that's pretty [ __ ] up
man did you get made fun of a lot in
school yes we'll see if you respond how
do you say your name was just initials
an acronym of a group that sounds like
vag VAG's office ah vac of mus are
calling you badge badge yeah
badge comment it again the filmmaker kit
98 I'm assuming you were born in 1998 or
you just really like the number and idea
for some reason I don't know why you
wouldn't go with a hundred but whatever
good for you for being a filmmaker man
and pursue those dreams that's what your
parents tell you when you're young you
know go pursue whatever you want then
you tell them you're going in the film
and they're like woah no getting agree
what the [ __ ] wrong with you yeah I
thought you're gonna be a doctor not an
artist yeah yeah you just to live the
dreams I want you to live so I'm sure
you're getting a lot of that crap for
being a filmmaker but you keep going and
you persist yeah yeah move to LA man you
come on the channel would be so much fun
if you did you can shoot us you can what
oh shoot us with a camera okay
just again I thought we were forming
like some suicidal thing right
okay cool you can murder let's see the
really doctor